oh so pumped correct
my alternate ego who loves television
commercials that is super passive
[Music]
I think by never relenting from the
conversation with myself about the
reality of the situation inevitable
you'll get to the moment of clarity if
you spend every minute recognizing this
is a [ __ ] problem and you know the
quicker I dress it and understand it and
respect it
the quicker I'm gonna get to the
solution listen this is why it's so
scary this is why I don't like that
everybody wants to be an entrepreneur
like if you're listening to us right now
you're like [ __ ] that sounds depressing
like what's fun about that it's the
truth if you want you know it's just to
me you can make money this way if you
don't want to deal with unbelievable
amounts of pressure if you don't have
the stomach for the pain and that's what
you know I know it's like being an
athlete like if you want to if you want
to work out every day and eat healthy
and like watch mail like it seems so
much more glamorous you know I think one
of the things to be extremely self aware
as a founder so when I started the
business I essentially had a chat with
myself and had myself acknowledge what
are the things I'm the [ __ ] best at
and then one of the things that I should
not be doing and step one was to
surround myself with people who could do
all the things that I am NOT great at
I'd say step three was having the
foresight to know what type of company
to build and then find operators who've
done it I think I don't need to reinvent
every aspect of the wheel there are
things that Gary does every single day
that are tried-and-true to building a
great company that I can learn from as I
say that was the starting place to
identify who are the people I should
initially surround myself with just jump
back before I move on one thing I've
been thinking a lot about is building up
self esteem and confidence how do you
find the right balance between
instilling confidence versus creating
delusion and entitlement I think it's an
extremely fine you like that one I think
it's you know I've been spending a lot
of time on this I'm just curious to get
your perspective on it I think it's an
extremely fine line and you know I think
that for example just being selfish for
a minute I think I've done too much of
that at Wine Library in vaynermedia
which is then created an undercurrent of
entitlement which takes a lot of time to
then correct and it's painful to start
introducing radical candor to massive
optimism how do you how do you how do
you think about having humility and
pride in your voice at the same time I
think is what the creates play authentic
communication so with my team like
knowing gets penalized for making small
mistakes because we're all human
I would say the big thing is if things
were happening over time and we gave
someone the benefit to show growth in
their role
you know then we would sit down and
talked about okay how do we put you on a
performance review that makes sense for
the business and help you achieve these
certain milestones so I think the fact
that I have such humility with my team
like Gary and I had a board meeting
yesterday I left the board meeting I go
back to my office and of course my team
you want to know how the board meeting
went I told them exactly how it went
because there's nothing to hide so I
told them the good the bad and having
that level of humility I think is the
balance with having pride in your own
voice have you studied you know you're
so early in your career you're on this
path but you are getting attention and
you're out and about have you started
mentoring yourself have you thought
about what that chapter looks like are
you still very much focused on you're
obviously early in the business focusing
on getting the value out of that
relationship of mentorship no I similar
to you Gary like I'm so self-critical so
I constantly probably to the detriment
every
evaluating like where the weaknesses in
my business and myself what's coming up
in my calendar that I feel like I need
help with and I'll tell you I feel like
one of the most underutilized words in
business right now is help and I've
actually like put that into practice so
it's a little bit about correcting
a beer when you have team members who
were kind of underperforming how do you
know
either I mean for me fear is just never
a good strategy even when it's not
working you know I I I'm flabbergasted
by people's inability to understand how
much more positive in optimal
articulated when somebody was struggling
how do we put you on a plan that works
for the business and works for you the
thought that fear or negativity is a
good idea is ludicrous you know there's
always a great way to do it I mean I'll
tell you one of the things I'm trying to
do a better job of is I'm spending way
more energy on the way we exit somebody
properly than the way that we onboard
them properly because I care so much
about the final taste and when it when
it's bad I feel like you know to me for
all of us that are leaders here CEO
c-suite what have you you work for them
and so you're in control and so for me
you know I think there's a time for
critical feedback you know to me the
cadence of positive reinforcement but
you may want to look at this and you
think about your words carefully and you
want to do it positive I do think
there's a come-to-jesus moment I think
you know after giving positive
reinforcement but you may want to work
on this there is a time of like you
probably suck you know and that's okay
like maybe we suck you know takes two to
tango but we need to figure this out
because nobody's winning here my point
of view is if you're not able to be the
bigger person in every situation when
you have the leverage you're weak and
you're creating vulnerability
and Lola would love to hear what's
different about what you're looking for
and maybe what differences I see in men
versus women
so this is something that Rachel and
Britt and the birches I like I've done a
lot of female you know what am I looking
for I'm looking for good [ __ ]
businesses and so like obviously over
the last half decade as the conversation
properly has been focusing on the
numbers that are matching up you know
one thing you know Rachel's like always
ragging on me for not talking enough
about how much female founder ship I've
done you know that is insane like like I
don't know that's that like I just like
I don't really pay attention to much
believe it or not like that is
unbelievably ridiculous and so you know
I remember so I wrote the first check
into Birchbox
right and so that was six or seven years
ago and I remember that meeting like it
was yesterday we were in Starbucks in
Midtown and they were pitching and they
probably got about 60 words in and I
said I was in and I remembered them
getting super pumped and emotional and
not you know like pretty emotional and I
remember um just was like what's like
who awesome like I was palm too but I
was like you know like and they were
just like we've gotten so many knows you
know like we needed this yes and I was
like cool like I've seen that before
like I would didn't think much of it and
it was super interesting it's probably
around this time of year it was that
first really nice day in New York City
after like the winter you know like that
perfect like I don't know if it was
April or May but it was that day I think
we all know what they that was and I was
ironically less busy back then so I
could actually walk home and I live in
the Upper East Side in that 30 block
walk I remember somewhere around halfway
being like
wait a minute like is it possible like
the business was so obvious to me it was
like we're gonna get samples and sell
them I was like that's a great [ __ ]
business and maybe I'm and at the time
at the time it was very social media and
it was a different world maybe because I
came from a retail background it clicked
but no question it was a time when I
went through my mind of like holy [ __ ]
are they getting knows because they're
women and and to be very frank I want to
be I'm a pretty transparent dude I
intuitively this is not I'm not proud of
this I wonder and I don't know if it's
true or not but I wonder if I even
subconsciously recognized that there was
going to be great opportunities for me
in female found businesses if the market
back to this 2% [ __ ] was gonna view
it I like to me I don't care if you're
an alien you know like the only like
only Patriot fans are the things that I
usually don't invest in but like it's
it's utterly embarrassing to me and not
as a guy it's utterly embarrassing me to
me as a business person in the game of
merit wins that those stats exist but
I'll be very frank about this and I'm a
big big big fan from afar of how Cindy
Gallup communicates this [ __ ] them like
I'm being dead serious like like there's
plenty of high net worth individuals out
there there's plenty of other ways to
get dollars or just make money from the
beginning like I'm like I'm so thrilled
that the Internet is here because no I
mean this the the mature Internet is
unbelievably the middle layer it is the
layer that we build on and that person
isn't some 52 year old you know Harvard
Business School Finance VC that's making
a subconscious bias for bias decision
the Internet is the middle and we don't
have to play and like first of all the
whole VC ecosystem forget about men and
women is not an exciting game to begin
with their model is predicated on
20 businesses way too hard and way too
fast with the hope that one breaks
through and pays for the whole nut
it is so not founder friendly in the
scheme of things so you know to me it's
like hearing that number like where I
really go in my head is like good
hopefully that makes all these badass
women in here think about alternative
ways to raise money because I don't
think he sees in their current state is
all that exciting I never felt like Gary
C's gender like you treat business
because I want to [ __ ] win it's
insane to me
it's I'm and there are other men out in
the world like Gary like one of the
reasons why I asked you here is I'm a
true believer that feminism will only
reach its pinnacle if men are a part of
the conversation and yeah it's just
looking for new ways to raise money like
I I don't enjoy the VC ecosystem and I
have many strategic investors at McMahon
question
[Music]
you